I want to know what is our opinion about
Kyoto Protocol and about the u.s.
position and general sign and good what
would be a good political solution for
this climate change is clearly the sort
of preeminent Commons challenge of our
time and it is a Commons challenge and
that means it clearly changes the
landscape you can't just deal with it on
a local basis I think so you asked about
the Kyoto Protocol in particular that
sort of passed I don't know that it's
really you know I do know that it hasn't
really achieved what was set out to
achieve I'm not not speaking well let me
speak first time behalf of the company
and then let me tell you my opinion okay
so on behalf of the company we do
believe that it's important to price
carbon it is an externality it does
obviously affect society in a very broad
way and not just future generations it's
now affecting current generations what's
tricky about it of course is that
anything we do now doesn't really have
an impact for quite some time we do
think it's important we think that it's
important that it be priced in a way
that levels the playing field so that
companies that are investing heavily and
reducing their their emissions aren't
being penalized for doing that we think
it's important that it be done in a way
that's predictable because frankly
unpredictable costs are really worth two
companies then slightly rising lofts and
that predictability if you really know
what the price is going to be or at
least are on a plausible trend that can
unleash capital investment in innovation
and innovation it's got what it's got to
be all about right and it's not just
innovation meaning entirely new
technologies but it may be innovative in
fact frequently as innovative business
models for applying those technologies
so so that's that's our broad position
and it includes the fact that we believe
that internet
tional collaboration cooperation
negotiation are critical and that it's
critical that we set the national goals
now specifically with regard to what
those international policies ought to be
as a company we have not taken a
position on that we're not experts in
that at all on a personal level I do
think that we stand more of a chance of
moving forward if we treat it like trade
and create multilateral and bilateral
agreements that create the same kind of
pull that the supply chain you know
sustainability creates by driving it
instead of through the supply chain by
driving it through through international
agreements and I think that has a better
chance than one global agreement and and
for that reason I'm I'm very heartened
by the us-china agreement and hope that
that just as a starting point for what
has to happen
so you said that you see is also in data
analytics right yes and I've done some
kind of research in data analytics I did
a project in that and I know it's the
next big thing I mean most of the
innovations likely to be carried out in
data analytics so I just like to know
what kind of business data indeed
analytics the dmz carry out is only just
supplying software modules or you do
take up individual projects and kind
carry out the data analysis and find out
the recipient the emc is actually has
what we call the federation of companies
so it comprises a couple of companies
and brands that together are driving
toward a particular vision of the next
generation of information technology the
three companies involved one is EMC
within EMC what we call EMC information
infrastructure and that's the storage
infrastructure and that's clearly a key
part of it big data analytics with the
volume of data and also the speed of
data actually requires some difference
in the underlying architectures in order
to best take advantage of that so that's
a huge part of the EMC offering um then
there's VMware are you I don't know if
you're familiar with VMware so a
software company that really
commercialized virtualization and EMC
owns about eighty percent of VMware and
so that virtualization that
software-defined data center
infrastructure is going to be critical
in terms of access to that data but
where the real sort of heart of the data
analytics is is Anna company called
pivotal and pivotal really has three
elements to the business one is software
for enabling data analytics the second
is actually software as a service which
is a big data applications it's actually
excuse me platform as a service so it's
a big data analytics development
platform that's provided as a service
and then the third element of that is
pivotal labs which actually does
agile development applications my
question is a little bit technical it's
AI mean it's about we are a data demand
is growing exponentially and we are
using the same technology for so many
years the mechanical hard disk for
example the SSD drivers are not going to
be able to compete in capacity neither
in cost but it would be a great
improvement in terms of a consumption
that will really make a change in the
sustainability of the of EMC how much do
you think we are going to keep having
this technology do this HD on HDD
technology in in terms of cloud
computing and service servers and that
stuff and what will you think it will be
the next technology I'm not the right
person to answer that question the exact
question which is what would be the next
technology and when will we stop
spinning disks basically however let me
say that it's not quite as dire as you
make out for a couple of reasons first
of all the actual hard disk technology
has substantially improved over the
years we've gone from you know a couple
of Meg to you know a couple of terabytes
on the spindle we have much more energy
efficient disk drives and we're using
software do things like spin down disk
drives or put them into more quiet
States and you see that in your own
laptops and so on so that's not so bad
what's more important is two things from
a hardware it's a hardware software
combination point of view and that is
what we're seeing is with the SSD is the
solid drive and with what we call fat
drives which are the slow big ones that
can you know they have a lot of capacity
they use much less energy because they
turn more slowly and so that their their
profile of energy consumption per unit
capacity is much much better than your
traditional district
that combination of the two overlaid
with software that can move hot data to
the SSDs and cold data to the big fat
drives can dramatically reduce energy
efficiency and it actually increases
performance often you know when properly
implemented because you're actually
taking the cold data away from the haunt
data so it's not competing with that
cold data and it actually happens on a
very granular level so there so software
when you combine that together with
things like compression and data
deduplication and so on software is
doing a lot of the management of that
data growth so it's so it's not quite so
dire but yes there certainly our drivers
to continue to find ways to manage the
data growth such that we're not having a
commensurate increase in energy
consumption resource consumption
footprint cost management costs and all
the other costs associated with did so
emc works in several sectors like
hardware software infrastructure
services cloud computing security
security as well your job is to promote
sustainability across all those sector
and probably across the globe which have
you find any sector that is very
challenging to improve that's a very
good question sometimes the harder
things to improve are the things where
it's not so much a sector as it is the
function so you know help having
engineers understand the role that they
play for example we put in place in 2013
a review of every product before it goes
out the door and we've actually set
goals by the way we've said goes for
energy efficiency of the hardware as
well over time but we've we look at
every product and do a review of the
product particularly from an energy
efficiency and energy manageability
point of view and without a doubt we've
received emails initially when we
started doing this from groups that said
we don't need to do this because we're
just software and we've had to come back
and say no you do need to do this
because how you design your software
affects how you use hardware and that
affects the energy consumption and the
material you use if our hardware is
forty percent more efficient than our
competitors and if the software is very
inefficient and requires twice as much I
then the system is less energy efficient
so so it you know where where the impact
is one step removed it's a little more
challenging to explain to people another
example is human rights is an important
issue in information technology and when
we think about human rights and we
didn't get a chance to speak about this
earlier we think a lot about the supply
chain and we should think a lot about
the supply chain there are many many
human rights issues in this deep a
supply chain but we're also looking at
downstream you know in what ways do we
affect the rights of citizens through
the ways in which our products are used
and helping you know engineers
understand how the decisions they make
them designing a product affect the
potential for protecting people's
freedom of expression for example is it
is a little bit more challenging because
it's it's more indirect but once once
people within that function you know get
it usually then then that takes off
truthfully hardware is the easiest you
know to to explain the impact because
because they're physical but but really
the impacts of every aspect of the
business actually Joe answer to my
second question I was about to us like
how would you promote sustainability in
a cell for setting but
you've got to see the system as a whole
this okay you know I got asked the
question about my career and I often
answer it at the end of the day by it's
all about systems I started in the
hardware which wasn't interesting until
we added an operating system and then I
got into networks you know and then I
thought well you know even the
technology wasn't that interesting until
I understood how it was being used in
the business and if you're always sort
of interested in the systemic context in
which your job resides you kind of end
up in sustainability the technology
industry has a height H of obsolescence
and the recycling is not so common in
all the areas so and we have a great
pressure about the shareholders how ABC
balance the growth pressure and increase
its sales with the environmental
friendly and social actions and praxis
balancing growth and sustainability
maybe sort of the core socio-economic
issue that we have to grapple with it I
don't think has been solved on a parodic
economic level yet I know it hasn't been
and we need to do work there within a
company it's a it's a little bit easier
in that for one thing we're to start our
our CEO likes to talk about that the
challenge of end or the power of end as
we do it every day we say we need to
reduce the cost of our products and we
need to improve quality and you know in
the days of your people would say that's
not possible because improving quality
includes it increases costs but that's
not true and we found ways to do that
and so the same thing is true in terms
of sustainability and growth we need to
serve our investors from a financial
perspective and we need to reduce our
impact now many of those reductions
actually save money because waste you
know producing waste costs money it uses
it uses materials so so those things
those things save money we talked
earlier about driving growth through
innovation which comes from attracting a
diverse pool of people it comes from
engaging your employees they feel a
sense of purpose so so there are a lot
of ways in which sustainability does
help drive that growth there are still
some challenges and one of the ways to
deal with those challenges step is to
set goals so we've set public balls
around a couple of things a number of
things our supply chain STEM education
but in particular around energy
efficiency of our products and around
greenhouse gas emissions reductions
setting that public all sort of
galvanized these people around those
goals and we set them not based on our
expected growth we set our golf based on
the science so contact set so not what
do we think we can do or what do we want
to do but what do we have to do at least
at emc I can't speak from other
companies we have a very strong culture
of execution you know if we've said
we're going to do something we are going
to find a way to do that and that drives
innovation you know Michael Eisner who
used to be CEO of disney I heard him
speak once and he said that you know we
talked about thinking outside of the box
he said real innovation comes from being
stuck inside a box when you feel like
you're over constrained and how do i how
do I rethink those constraints right and
so that I can find another path out and
I I think that that challenges is
helping us to do you've talked about
that no movement challenge that IT
industry faces right now is the talent
so I just like to know your thoughts
about retaining talent identifying
talent and in general new ideas about
leadership you want to find people that
have not only the obvious skills that
you're hiring for but really have sort
of the the ability they have agility
they have teamwork they
our creative they are engaged it's have
you read any anything by daniel pink so
Daniel pink writes about what's
important to the workforce and I've been
very inspired by him and he says that in
today's workforce really wants three
things they want autonomy that means you
know work when and where I want to work
and the way in which I want to work and
with the team that I want to work so I
think he says time technique multiple DS
any autonomy mastery a sense then I am
contributing that I look that I've got
something to offer that I've that I've
mastered I don't think you want to feel
like I know everything there is to know
but you want to feel like I know
something that I'm bringing to the table
and then sends a purpose there's a
reason why I'm doing that he also said
that that's all laid out in a book he
wrote called drive there's also another
book he wrote about the importance of
right brain skills in the new world
we've tended to be very linear I alluded
to this before the kinds of things that
you put on a resume yet those aren't
really the indicators of success and by
success I mean both for the individual
and for the company so that it's it's
productive for both of them there is no
question that when you've met those
things that retention goes way up and
your thoughts on leadership my thoughts
on leadership leadership there are many
different styles of leadership actually
just took a an instrument to that
assesses your style of leadership so I
think there are many styles i don't
think leadership is given to you by the
people above you it's it's absolutely
something that is recognized by the by
your peers and and the people who work
work with and for you i believe that the
best path to leadership
making people around you successful
helping them to be successful and again
I go back to defining the success so
they have to feel successful in a
personal level and they have to feel
successful on a professional level there
are people who say that's what I do when
what they mean is they think that making
people successful means just do whatever
someone higher than you told you to do
you need to make them successful and it
is undoubtedly good for your career to
make your boss successful but I really
think the leadership comes from making
your peers in your workers success
related to the new developments of
technology for example electric cars
solar panels or whatever usually they
have a kind of trade-off between in the
first steps they are very some
undercover process that makes them not
really sustainable for example in
electric cars and manufacturing the
batteries is really a really disruptive
for environment as a as a sustainability
manager what would you do and progress
and do they do the development the early
developments for the sake of developing
that system or would you would you like
to wait until the whole process is
greener than the one that was before I
think it's absolutely necessary to
invest in an innovation and
experimentation somebody has to do that
and furthermore I think somebody has to
engage in it so not only do people who
are doing and have to invest in it but
but consumers have to invest in and yes
i drive an electric car and yes i know
that it's not fully sustainable frankly
i don't think anything is fully
sustainable i do think it's very
important that we do it with open eyes
and an open understanding of what those
impacts are a recognition of them and
continue to work towards towards
adjusting them now if you're further
down the chain
it's interesting we talked about this
earlier it's a little bit harder to do
so if you take solar panels for example
the learning curve for selling solar
panels has been very steep I'm really
long mm-hmm it's but from a financial
perspective it's been very short
actually the prices have come down
substantially the efficiency is going up
it would be nice about when I'm faster
and somebody has to invest in in doing
that but as a consumer downstream we
struggle with that you know years ago if
we had bought a solar for some of our
facilities we'd still be paying it off
when things we buy now would already
have been paid off all right so you know
you have a nine-year payoff period about
two years ago and if you bite now you
have a five-year payoff period which
should you have done so so I think it's
very important really to consider the
entire lifecycle and then make a
conscious decision and know why you're
doing that and then look back and
measure and see whether it achieved what
you set out to do but if you wait for
the entire system to be perfect nothing
will get nothing mom move just like the
international agreements if you wait for
that to be perfect it's not going to
happen regarding that and for example in
Europe and when there is a really great
restriction about solar panels yeah and
so if you want to buy a solar panel in
China you are going to have to pay a lot
of taxes in order to make the costs
equality right because China is not
really sustainable that's so there are a
couple of things embedded in there when
we talked about the agreements I
actually I talked about leveling the
playing field between companies but we
also have to level the playing field
between countries so there are no free
riders so I agree with you and I think
that tying this a little bit to trade
make sense I'd be a little bit careful
about China's not sustainable well guess
what none of us are sustainable but and
they're also investing more in it than
anybody else is either so I'm not sure
which way to go on that one you know yes
they're building a coal plant to every I
don't know what
the numbers are now week two weeks you
know on the other hand are invested that
somebody needs to invest in in driving
that learning curve on solar and wind
and biomass and geothermal and China is
actually investing a lot more in it than
many other places so I'm a little bit
ambivalent about China I can't put them
in completely the bad guy or a complete
good guy category they're both I always
remember what they said that like
Western world didn't make sustainability
actions for a century why should we do a
now right and that's I cannot you can
certainly understand that and it's
really important to allow opportunity
for people in in other parts of the
world and so the question is you know
how do you develop economic opportunity
and health care and education you know
opportunity which are really critical is
just from a humanitarian perspective
never mind for business and social
stability and all of those things I mean
how do you do that in a way that's
that's more sustainable and is also fair
and unfortunately it is going to take it
absolutely is going to take commitments
on both the developed and developing
worlds and the developed world yes we
have to do more than our part of me we
are especially here in the US we are
terrible over consumers and if your
honor if you've ever looked at the
global footprint project and the u.s. is
that something like four and a half
times what an individual share should be
of using using earth resources and we
need to understand that and find ways
ourselves to be more sustainable but not
but at the same time work together to
provide these you know foundational
societal services for people in
developing
you always talk about solar energy but
some it is to existing some constraints
about the cost and about the technology
to produce in your opinion what be a
alternative energy for this issue with
less pollution but with a production
like so at the moment I think we have to
pursue exploring all of them because in
different places I'll be different some
places tidal energy will work out well
geothermal is wonderful in some
geographies I still I still think Solar
is going to be huge particularly in
continents like Africa where there's so
much Sun to be harvested but we have a
lot of technology work to do on that so
at the same time this goes all the way
back to your your policy question one of
the reasons I believe it's important to
price carbon is to to really create that
initial investment that reduces
long-term risk and it there is a
long-term risk associated obviously with
greenhouse gas emissions long-term risk
to society and we're not counting that
into the business cases that we're
making and so that's why we are starting
now to apply a shadow price of carbon
that is our best current estimate of
what the economic cost is to the company
of having higher emissions so hopefully
that will will drive more investment in
renewables at the same time we are
signatories to a set of principles that
was produced recently called the
corporate renewable energy virus
principles that we're using to sit down
with utilities around the u.s. to say
these are the things we're looking for
we actually don't want to become energy
producers I'd be just as happening my
utility could offer it to us but we have
to have high confidence that it is
sustainable
or pretty sustainable comparatively it
sustainable and that its additional so
that if we're paying for renewable
energy it's causing more renewable
energy to be generated as opposed to
just taking a share of something that
was going to be produced anyway due due
to legislation so so these kinds of
conversations are underway we're not
dictating what's the technology but it
does need to make good financial sense
taking into consideration they'll cause
a greenhouse gas emissions